la parole est à monsieur bruno belin
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
le débat ouvert par dominique estrosi
sassone est essentielle cet après midi
il n'y a pas d'avenir sans bâtir alors
oui oui oui il faut construire plus
parce que ça a été dit carence de
logements manquent de logements sociaux
manquent de logements étudiants manquent
de logements adaptés
le grand âge a du mal à se loger est
évidemment la carence de logements fait
augmenter les prix
et puis aller effectivement le mieux et
le mieux génère deux questions d'abord
le comment et là moi j'entends pas dans
vos propos les efforts de recherche sur
les questions de défis climatiques de
formation et ça c'est essentiel
le mieux construire se fera avec des
nouvelles méthodes et de nouveaux
matériaux et puis avec question du où
hélas tous les projets vous avez parlé
de 500 communes y en a 35 1800 france
tous les projets sont essentiellement
urbain parce qu'il ya plus de projets
possibles dans la ruralité l'épée et lui
vont sont les ennemis des maires ruraux
et ça ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure par
notre collègue l'eau quel projet madame
proposez-vous pour la ruralité
comment obtenir un moratoire sur la mise
en place d p lui des scot
ça c'est la vraie question des
territoires ruraux et donc de l'avenir
des territoires
les français ont besoin d espace aux
envies des espaces c'est le message de
l'été dernier donc donné aux françaises
et aux français les moyens de vivre là
où il ya de l'espace merci vous avez
l'air parole madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le sénateur je pense
qu'effectivement on est au coeur du
débat construire plus et construire
mieux pour construire plus j'aimerais
juste m'arrêter sur un des aspects vous
avez mentionné qui est le grand âge et
l'adaptation au vieillissement c'est
effectivement une des dimensions
importantes du besoin à laquelle nous
devons répondre nous le faisons à la
fois avec des aides là aussi en
partenariat avec action logement pour
l'adaptation des logements au
vieillissement sont des choses très
concrètes de changement de baignoires en
douche par exemple mais aussi dans le
développement de
habitat inclusif et a été votée dans le
dernier plfss la dernière loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
création d'une nouvelle aide l'aide à la
vie partagée qui finance la possibilité
pour des personnes âgées d'habiter
ensemble dans de l'habitat intermédiaire
entre chacun chez soi ou vraiment un
établissement spécialisé avec le
financement de services
je visite de plus en plus de projets
dans lesquels ses formes d'habitat
inclusif prennent leur place et je pense
que c'est important et ce sera une
réponse à l'un des défis de notre
société le vieillissement
vous parliez ensuite dû construire mieux
bien sûr que le ministère soutient à
travers notamment le programme
d'investissements d'avenir la recherche
sur les matériaux construire mieux c'est
changer de matériaux nous avons donné un
objectif dans la haie revin réduire les
émissions de la construction de 30 %
avec une ligne directrice la mixité des
matériaux chacune des filières doit
trouver ses innovations pour permettre
cette réduction
il n'y a pas de filière tabou toutes les
filières peuvent le faire et la
recherche existent dans toutes les
filières ciment béton acier bâtiment
biosource bête matériaux biosourcés mais
je pense aussi aux bâtiments aux
matériaux pardon comme la terre cuite ou
autre donc cette réponse existe et nous
allons continuer à la développer
enfin j'entends oui la terre cuite tout
à fait c'est un matériau qui revient à
l'ordre du jour et qui est extrêmement
efficace avec de grandes qualités
environnementales
enfin comment construire partout
moi j'entends cet appel à la ruralité je
les dis d'ailleurs tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment une opportunité
après il va falloir qu'on continue ce
débat sur pourquoi est-ce qu'à
l'intérieur du bloc communal
certains élus seraient les grands
gagnants et les rumeurs d'autres merci
monsieur belin vous avez 58 secondes
c'est beaucoup et c'est noël merci
madame la présidente
alors deux trois choses d'abord moi je
suis sidéré que dans le débat on
n'entende pas parler aussi des
entrepreneurs et des artisans
parce que pour construire demain ça
falloir permettent la transmission
d'entreprise la transmission du savoir
faire la transmission du maçon du
village et de son outil de travail et de
son savoir faire et ça il faut vraiment
connaît ce sujet là un moment donné et
puis vous avez parlé du grand âge
j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse connaître
l'efficacité des fonds anna et la
facilité parce que quand vous avez quand
vous atteignez le grand âge faire un
dossier anna et attendre les accords
pour que les travaux se fassent relève
d'un parcours difficile et puis enfin
pour la rue alerté il ya une mesure
simple fait passer une directive demain
à tous les préfets pour qu'ils arrêtent
de bloquer les projets en milieu rural
sous prétexte qu'il ya un pelli en
attente ça c'est un vrai sujet sur
lequel on reviendra devant vous et
devant cette assemblée
merci